hello and welcome to episode 7 of game
on I am Todd Kerpelman i am your host
and a developer advocate on the play
games team I'm Wolff Dobson I'm a
developer programs engineer on the play
games team and we're here to talk to you
about the latest in the Play game
services API we're here to talk about
management tools and we're going to end
with a special surprise and I want to
give too much away but it's it's a graph
so I guess I kind of gave it away all
right let's move on to news and updates
we don't really have any not a whole lot
kind of happened it's going great it's
been it's been relatively keep loading
those games keep playing games and I
guess no news is good news so we'll move
on to this week's topic which are the
management api's these are a set of
api's we've had available for a while
but i'm not sure people have taken
advantage of them to the extent that
they should have and so wolf has wolf
has come to the rescue on behalf of all
you developers and he's made life easier
for you so we're gonna have him talk
about it alright so the admin tools uh
this is linked to the docs if you want
to check them out yourself basically
they are a bunch of rest calls that
allow you to do certain sort of
management tasks like reset achievements
hide players on high score lists unlock
achievements that sort of thing reset
your score you got it while you're in
testing and I'm bet when I say that
you're thinking I don't want to make all
these rush calls myself I wish somebody
actually written that for me and the
answer is somebody has and that person
is me so let's take a look so here's the
first of three tools this is the play
games score o matic and what this allows
you to do is set and reset leader board
scores so this is the leader board from
firewall defense bruno's excellent game
and I can get the scores that I've
submitted now I haven't submitted in any
scores so let's let's make myself score
a whole bunch of scores I'm going to
score 10,000 points and it says great
your score is submitted
and then if I call get my scores I've
scored 10,000 points and I'm first in my
social group of 20 but how come you're
listed three times there that's four
all-time high score weekly high score
and daily high score okay and I can
reset all the scores with one click of
the button I'm reset link and when i get
my scores again I've disappeared ah this
would be very useful if say we're
testing our game our scoreboard is full
of like you know our testers that have
either found bugs to like get
ridiculously high scores and we're like
oh man we got to clear this out before
we yeah or we live or you have a system
that does something special when you get
daily high scores or something like that
you want to be able to set that off
again and again so this is a way for you
to reset that you can only reset your
high score you can't reset everybody's
high score okay that's probably
important okay next up is the reset o
matic the reset o matic is the same
thing except for achievements so here we
have a list of achievements in firewall
defense I'm going to I'm going to take
this cadet thing and I'm going to unlock
it today achievement unlocked and when i
refresh this so you can see it is now
unlocked hooray I could also for an
incremental achievement incremented and
I can also just say I didn't win that on
second thought and when i refresh it is
now is now still revealed rather than on
lot revealed hair meaning that I I
always find our achievement States
confusing revealed means that you know
what the achievement is but you haven't
earned it yet right as opposed to hidden
or unlocked which means you've actually
achievement unlocked yes and so this is
incredibly useful if again we're testing
achievements before our game goes out
and we want to kind of practice earning
an achievement we want to test that over
and over again we don't have to you know
create 500 test accounts we just know
you didn't want to do that yeah reset
this gmat you'd be sad ok so then lastly
we have the high dometic and the high
dramatic is the one that you're really
going to use possibly you know from week
to week when you're developing your
so this is the main high score list for
for firewall defense and you might look
through here and you say well all these
guys got their scores legitimately but
you know when I say I look through here
I see bruno and you know Buddha was the
developer of the game it's clear he
didn't score those 6,000 points by
himself no way so I'm going to go here
and i'm going to say be gone i'm going
to hide you forever and so this player
is now hidden and if i refresh high
scores and I page the second page you
can see there's no Bruno there any
longer that's totally cool and if I
decide to have mercy and Bruno and bring
him back I can click unhide and he's
unhidden it'll take 12 hours for Bruno
to reappear it's a little priority job
so you know it's going to come back when
it's going to come back now when you
hide this player are they hidden from
all leaderboards or just this particular
leaderboard no they're there they're
hidden from all leaderboards okay all
right well those are the management
tools these are all open source you can
get them from yourself from github from
our regular samples and I guess it's
probably worth noticing compared to most
of our sample apps that are like hey
here's a sample that you can kind of see
how it works but then you need to go and
like make your own game kind of you know
and copy and paste bits here and there
from our samples this is really intended
for people to essentially use as an
entire application download this thing
they run it yeah and in fact I guess
probably you can walk us through the
setup steps but it really is hey this is
the code that you should be using on
your own uh and and because of API you
can expand it any way you want yeah all
right well let's take a look at how
we're going to set this out for you to
use these tools you're going to need to
host them someplace they're just a
couple of HTML pages and some JavaScript
pages you'll need to put them someplace
local host even works for testing you're
going to need to link a web application
in the console and you're going to need
to go into these JavaScript and the HTML
files and replaced a couple of constants
in this case clienti app ID and in the
high dometic you need the leaderboard so
even if you don't have a web version of
your game
which probably applies to a lot of
remote yeah exactly a lot of your
developers you're going to need to put
the you're going to need to link a web
application anyway and this web
application is actually you know its
your game so you should be careful with
those credentials like you would
normally so sorry just to clarify i'm
not going to create a new application
that's my admin for my angry fruit game
i'm actually going to go into my angry
fruit game and i'm going to link a new
web-based clan is just a tortoise it's a
web version of your you're angry fruit
game okay and you're going to fill out
where you wanted to point to and you're
going to create a client ID and when you
create the client idea for the web
console you need to set your JavaScript
origins to wherever you're hosting these
pages in this case i have it on
localhost but you could also have suit
just on a server inside your firewall or
even public although you'd have to be
pretty careful with that URL ah it is
worth noting that this is in fact a
version of your game it's just a version
of your game with your game missing and
just the leaderboards and scoreboard
stuff in there and so if you have a
javascript origin set to localhost it
means that anybody else can download
this and they can go to the web version
of your game they can pull out the
client ID and then app ID and paste
those into your things and like unlock
all the achievements and give themselves
arbitrary score they won't be able to do
the management tasks because you have to
be on you have to be an owner or on the
tester list to use those tasks to use
those things but they will be able to
you know sort of obviously just set
their scores arbitrarily and that you
want to be careful with that so I would
advise if your game is launched you
probably want to set your JavaScript or
origin do something besides localhost
probably an internal server that's
inside your firewall ok let's go on to
the Q&A oh alright oh you got something
changing your JavaScript origins why'd
you want to do this again after you've
launched your game you went stolen or do
management tasks so that you can change
that from that you'd go to the api's
console or I guess coming soon the cloud
console and change this is basically
where we could change our settings to be
like I don't want to be on localhost
anymore i want to be on the internal
server google
or whatever well from that google icon
yeah unless you're us yeah we're
probably not you okay here we go all
right so uh yeah first question it looks
like so I very clearly I would want to
use this hide mechanism if it looks like
somebody is doing something kind of
nefarious or they're being a jerk and
they're like hey I'm gonna get a fake
score up on there because I'm a lead
hacker so why not just ban these players
um you could ban them but then they
might notice and they might get angry
and come after you again but also you
know I really you know there's they're
still going to appear in their social
scoreboards and so if somebody looks and
says the guy yea he's still got the
highest score that's great but they may
be ruining the experience for the people
in the public the public boards so this
allows them just to be like well they're
not going to appear on the public boards
and then uh they will when they look at
the public board they'll still see
themselves but if anybody else looks to
the public board they will not be there
alright so that's probably something to
make sure hiding needs hide from
everybody except the cheating or be out
of your hidden player the adverse player
yes so they they wouldn't even know that
they've been hidden unless like they
were to get another friend with an
account to look at the leaderboards oh
look at the public leader publicly they
will appear in the social network like a
lot of work yeah I guess I suppose the
other advantages if you hide someone
that you suspect it has gotten a score
through nefarious purposes and then it
turns out they're just a really really
good player you do have the option to
unhide them can put them right back and
all of their old scores will still be
there right and and another real real
use is that you have a bunch of testers
who've been playing it in beta and they
all have really high scores and you're
like I don't want to destroy your guys's
score but really we need to get that off
there so people can have a chance all
right makes sense yeah now using this
tool could I for instance you know my
customer service people someone emails
me and says hey I didn't get this
achievement can we grant them that
achievement using this tool no you need
a valid access token for each account to
be able to unlock achievements or lock
achievements for them so the idea is
this is really used for unrevealed so
have to reveal this is really just used
for testing purposes my testers have
earned the achievements they want to
practice earning the achievements again
or they wanted
that scenario again so we can get them
all back to the original state yeah the
player hiding is the only thing you can
do to somebody else and again only if
you're an owner of the application yeah
I guess that kind of links into our
third question sort of what you
mentioned how do it how do I know who is
who has access to these labels so for
the testing tools you just need to be on
the test your list in the play games
developer console and chances are that's
the one you've got to add so that people
can try your game before any game
services has been published right and
Lee and the owner of the application is
the person who can do to hiding in an ID
okay and you have to sign in as that
person when you're using this
application gotcha alright so even if
somehow yeah I were too yeah I were to
get your client ID and I'm on your on
localhost i'm still using that and i do
all that stuff you said you know yeah if
you look if you must rely on the dinner
make sure logged in as as that person
you can't make change anything or as an
owner and hopefully you're not leaking
your owner credentials yeah okay that
would be bad that would be bad well
alright great I think that's everything
we have on management tools and so will
we got to get you out of here so we have
room for we have time for a graph so uh
oh you're on hey no oh hey it's Javier
have you are welcome why you introduce
yourself yes well I'm come here
Schneider from the Google Play Games
team what you're young and you're here
to talk to talk about a graph that we're
about to see so um I um you know I've
got this whole seat here i think i
really only need the edge because we're
about to reveal it right now okay hey
check that out okay so what I'm looking
at what is okay well this is an
improvement in the unreliable latency
between peers in a real-time multiplayer
games okay so yeah I mean I know we've
you know we launched multiplayer
matchmaking at Google i/o a few months
ago since then we've been we've been
sort of you know iterating and improving
one of those areas has been yeah yeah
that's basically to got much quality so
what is this this is a factor that we
are always trying to improve in
our matchmaking system so the players
can have a better experience in the
matches that we create so is it looks
like a couple weeks ago this graph took
a nice little a nice little depth yes so
what is this we started considering the
broad geographic the broad geographic a
place of our players to estimate the
Latin see that they are going to have
when we form the they match gotcha so
like you basically now kind of prefer
like if I am somewhere and say Seattle
you're saying hey we're gonna try and
match you with other people in the
Pacific Northwest area because chances
are you'll have better better latency
than if we match you excited I end so
yeah this is something tricky because we
don't know they write latency after they
match is form and at that point is too
late to choose a different player you
can't kick someone out for having low
lanes no of course not so what we have
to do is to collect data for all the
matches between all the regions around
the world and we doing that data we
estimate what is likely to be the
latency between two players in different
visions so it doesn't necessarily have
to be the same region if we know that
for some reason you know City a and City
be have a really good internet
connection between us it's our gear
system would say oh it's ok to match up
these yes exactly so yeah I essentially
we do that and we this feature we get
better quality in the matches as you can
see in the graph yeah we have almost
fifteen or twenty percent improvement
that looks like is yeah so were there
any trade-offs involved in it is always
curve so if we have a match or we when
we are forming a match we see that this
match is not really good quality or the
latency is likely to be not so good
but we don't have other players they are
probably we have to wait a little longer
to combine the matches in in order to
wait for new players to arrive and see
if they have better better quality or
better expected latency between them so
this is the trade-off so maybe we need
the players to wait a little longer
before we from the matches gotcha so
what you're saying is you know for
instance I might be ready to play and
the only other you know player available
right now is in you know Australia or
somewhere we're far away you know
probably slower longer latency the
system's going to say we're not going to
match you up with that guy we're going
to have to we're going to look for
somebody else with a better connection
and so it might take me longer to get
into a match because I'm not going to
play this guy in Australia yes but of
course we don't want our players to wait
too much so what we also estimate is the
waiting time to another player to appear
for this particular game and if we think
that it's going to be too long we don't
wait on combine the players right away
so you sort of you change based on you
change the criteria a little bit based
on how popular game is how many players
are playing multiplayer at that time
yeah exactly and this is something that
is dynamically adjusted so for each
application each variant and each moment
we calculate all these variables and
decide if white is a good idea or not so
then we we purifies these two things to
have a good quality but also not to wait
too much that the player drop the
montreux or whatever so for instance in
a very popular game you could afford to
reject you know players that are too far
away might not have a good connection
because we know that there's constantly
new people coming in and that I won't
have to wait too much longer to find a
matching player wears a game where you
know it's you know it's just been
released or it's not very popular no
one's playing multiplayer even if some
connection isn't optimal the system will
say you know we're gonna try and match
you with him anyway because at least
it's better to have some some game they
no game at all yeah exactly that's the
idea by the way we don't reject players
which asks i choose to combine them with
other player you're actually I should
take I should make better language yes
we love all of our players we just yes
okay okay so this is it that is that's
very cool so so so basically our players
should be noticing a better multiplayer
experience yeah and a video yeah and
over time you know as as you adjust
these you know these matching systems
and I guess as more people start playing
multiplayer you'll start to see
improvements as well yes yes so another
thing that maybe in the future happened
is if a player or developers want to
improve based on the skills of the
players we can do some similar stuff
I've seen I've seen requests for that
the public database of like hey you know
I want to match you know advanced
players with advanced players or people
of the same difficulty level but I guess
you do have a good point where there's a
trade-off there where if we start you
know not matching people with with
potential opponents just because maybe
they're not the same skill level the
wait time is going to is going to go up
and depending on sort of how picky we
get it could you know the more factors
we kind of have to wait until we get a
perfect match the longer the wait I'm
could be yes but of course we have to
consider all these features or these
parameters when when we try to combine
matches for players and of course we
don't always the wait time it's a very
important factor and we don't want our
players to wait too much so that you
yeah so yeah it sounds like sounds like
a tricky problem yeah it's it's not a
simple one and again the major problem
is that you don't know all the
information after until is too late to
take the optimal decision so
custom ate a lot of details to do this
process well I'm glad you're working on
it and not me alright well I think that
wraps up this episode of game on I'd
like to thank wolf and have here for
joining us and we will see you in in two
weeks thank you very much Internet
audience